I get asked this question of geez I
haven't meditated how do I get started
and it's hard for many people because
what many of us don't appreciate is that
and I use the term in my book a DJ but
it's this internal dialogue and it is a
dialogue that isn't necessarily who you
really are at all it is a collection of
events experiences commentaries from
your environment that oftentimes you
allow to define you and not necessarily
in a positive way and as a result you
have an emotional response when you're
listening to these voices or this
dialogue or the DJ if you will and the
first thing that I recommend people do
and certainly is one of the sort of the
basis or the legs of doing mindfulness
or meditation is to simply breathe in
and out and be attuned to that and as
you get distracted if it's really
distracting actually consciously think
about the air going through your nose
and exhaling through your mouth
and the very nature of that type of
concentration distracts you from the
dialogue and once you've mastered that
and you pay attention to the fact that
oftentimes your muscles are very tense
because again you're carrying your
emotions and with intention go through
actually and say I'm relaxing the
muscles in my feet my legs my chest my
abdomen so forth and sort of go through
this process of with intention doing
each one of these things and with that
intention it also distracts you from
listening to that voice and once you've
done that for a period of time then you
suddenly realize the very nature of that
action and the consistency of that
you're no longer having that same
emotional response or you're not
starting to listen to that dialogue and
that starts releasing you and then the
next step as you learn these techniques
the wonderful thing is you can actually
change the dialogue and change it to one
where it is a supportive dialogue one of
the greatest challenges of people in the
West is they have this negative internal
dialogue and it's the nature
unfortunately of our society in Eastern
cultures actually it's interesting it
doesn't really exist and so when you if
you will stop the DJ and then change the
dialogue to one that is nurturing
supportive of yourself the most
wonderful thing that happens is your
physiology changes and then the manner
in which you react or interact with
other people becomes completely
different and have you been through this
myself and seen this and taught this
it's really quite extraordinary the
possibilities because when you take the
time to do that breathing when you take
the time if you will to tame the mind
when you take the time to open your
heart and recognize then not only are
you suffering but that everyone and some
way or other has their own burdens all
of those steps then allow you to be much
more thoughtful kind and interested
because then you recognize that the
other person is just like you and when
you recognize that key aspect then what
you do to others you're doing to
yourself and if you treat yourself with
kindness compassion love it's so much
easier than to give that gift to other
people and it changes not only that
other person it changes the entire
environment around you
[Music]